[MUSIC]
When they invited me I just though about
like, talk about what.
I didn't wanna give another talk about
globalization, or the middle east I
thought
I'd actually talk to you today about what
I do which is writing a column.
And how to write a column, what
constitutes a column and what I've
learned in the process of writing a column
for the last 20 years.
So that's what my talk is gonna be about
today.
Be three parts, let's say the first part
will be about where my own opinions came
from.
What, what are the roots of, of my outlook
on the world.
The second part will be about the nine
different kinds of columns.
And for there are many more, but to me
there are at least nine.
And the last part'll be about what I've
learned.
I'm actually thinking about turning this
in to a book.
And it all kind of started, the idea.
Really just about three months ago I was
in Saudi Arabia.
And I was meeting with a group from the
Acumen Fund.
And and entrepreneurial philanthropy.
The Saudi chapter.
Who knew that there was a Saudi chapter?
But there is.
And a very impressive group of young Saudi
men and women were
meeting at the home of one of the women in
the group.
And after dinner, we were sitting around.
We were sitting around with these young
Saudis and they
were asking me about how do you write a
column?
And I said once, well, she taught a course
once for my, other
daughter, Williams College during their
winter term on how to write a column.
And I said there were really just nine
kinds of columns.
And if you write one of these nine, you've
got a column.
And I started ticking them off as we were
sitting around the table.
And I noticed right in the middle of it.
They all took out their cell phones, and
were
writing down with their thumbs everything
I was saying.
[INAUDIBLE] And when, when one missed one,
was, I missed number four.
Did you get four?
What was seven?
You know?
And I was sort of watching this process,
and thinking about it afterwards.
And it really struck me, that we are in an
age now where everyone wants to, and can,
really opine.
And be a columnist.
You know, I always tell people, when I
started the New York
Times, as a columnist, in January 1995, I
actually inherited James Reston's office.
[INAUDIBLE] in the Washington Bureau of
the New York Times.
What a great thrill and honor to have the
office that was used
by this great columnist and editor of the
times in the 60s and 70s.
And I suspect when Mister Reston came to
the office back in the 60s and 70s.
He would start every day by saying, I
wonder
what my seven competitors are gonna write
about today?
And he personally knew all seven of his
competitors.
I can name them.
Walter Lippmann, Mary [UNKNOWN],
[INAUDIBLE] Alsop, Joseph.
Craft, Tony Lewis, I, I know them.
I now do the same thing, I come to the
office every day and I
say to myself, I wonder what my 70 million
competitors are going to write today.
[LAUGH]
I have 70 million competitors, cuz we do
live in a world where.
Anyone who has access to a blog is
now a potential columnist, everyone who
has access
twitter is a reporter, anyone with access
to
YouTube is a film maker, or a paparazzi.
And so so many people now are engaged in,
or pining about the world.
In their own ways and I think it's
actually very exciting and it's very rich
and everyone is doing it in their own way
and what
I want to talk to you about for the next
40 minutes or
so and then we'll have some Q and A, is
what is my way.
I don't know that it's the best way.
It certainly isn't the only way, but I can
tell you it's my way.
Now my way starts and I think every
columnist has to
start with with a point of view with a
take on the world.
No one's interested, in your disconnected,
thoughts.
Everyone has a take on the world, and if I
do write this, up in a book, this chapter
will be called, always looking for
Minnesota.
You won't understand my way, without
understanding where I come from.
And how my world view was shaped.
So let's go back to the beginning.
When I first fell in love with journalism.
It all starts back in Minnesota, with my
own version of the Jersey Boys.
The musical about the 1960s singing group,
the Four Seasons.
Led by Frankie Valli.
It's one of my favorite musicals, and I
particularly like the
opening monologue when the group's
founder, Tommy Devito, locates their
beginning.
Devito comes onstage, following a French
rendition of
the Four Season's Classic, Oh What a
Night.
And, he begins by saying, that's our song,
Oh
What a Night, [FOREIGN] French, number 1
in Paris.
2000.
How'd that happen?
You ask four guys, you get four different
versions, but this is where all of them
start.
Bellville, New Jersey, 1000 years ago.
Eisenhower, Rocky Marciano, and a few guys
under
a street lamp singing somebody else's
latest hit.
Every time I listen to that riff it
transports me back to my own roots.
To this day, I pinch myself that I've been
the
foreign affairs columnist for The New York
Times for 20 years.
How did that happen?
You ask my family and friends, you get 40
different versions.
But this is where all of them start.
Minnesota.
A thousand years ago.
Hubert Humphrey, 10,000 lakes, the
Minnesota Vikings, and a
few guys and girls, including me, growing
up in a tiny, one high school suburb
outside of Minneapolis called St. Louis
Park.
Something was in the water there in the
1960's.
During those post-war years, this tiny
community, St. Louis Park, ten square
miles,.
Was the birthplace or childhood home of
the
movie directors, the Coen Brothers, Joel
and Ethan Coen.
Political scientist Norman Ornstein.
Senator and former comedian, Al Franken.
Classical guitarist Sharon Isbon.
Chicago Bears football coach Mark Tristan.
Film director Joe Nussbaum.
Harvard University political philosopher
Michael Nussbaum.
And yours truly.
We all grew up in about six block radius
of one another during the 60s.
The Coen brothers, you may know, based
their 2009 movie A Serious Man
on St. Louis Park circa 1967 and
among other things memorialized our Hebrew
school.
When they were young, the Coen brothers
often hung out at
Mike Zoss Drugs on Minnetonka Boulevard, a
few miles from my house.
And if you look closely in their classic
film No
Country For Old Men, the pharmacy just
across the Mexican
border that the lead character Chigurh,
played by Javier Bardem,
enters to get medicine after he blows up a
parked car.
Is called Mike's [INAUDIBLE] Pharmacy.
Vice President Mondale once asked me to
speak for
his Minneapolis law firm and in
preparation for introducing me,
interviewed the Cohan brothers, Frank and
Ornstein, on what they
thought was going on in Saint Louis Park
back then.
Frank had said, when people hear that the
five of
us all grew up in the same suburb, they're
astonished.
What's in the water, they sometimes joked.
But it's not a joke.
During our childhood, at St. Louis park,
it was home to a
large creosote plant, which leached tons
of toxic materials into the groundwater.
Studies have shown that ingesting large
quantities of creosote can lead
two things increased levels of
intellectual creativity and or prostate
problems.
The Cohen brothers compare Saint Louis
park to the small
region in Hungary that had produced
numerous nuclear physicists and draculas.
My English teacher, Miriam Kagel, who
later taught journalism at
Park High told the Jewish Daily Forward,
it was partly rooted
in the migration of Jews to St. Louis Park
from the
inner city of Minneapolis, the northside,
in the 40s and 50s.
It was the time of great political ferment
had reached the Midwest and
people were just full of ideas and
protests and opinions and speaking their
mind.
I think there is something to that.
In my case, my parents subscribed to Time,
and Life magazines, and
to both the morning and afternoon
newspapers, the Minneapolis Tribune and
Minneapolis Star.
That is where I trace my love of
journalism, and opinion writing.
I don't know why, but from the moment I
started
reading newspapers, probably from in
junior highschool, I enjoyed reading
columnists.
I can still see myself coming home from
school, picking up the Minneapolis Star
and spreading
it out on the livingroom floor and reading
Peter Listagor's syndicated column from
the Chicago Tribune.
I devoured Time Magazine as soon as it
arrived,
and I got my first experience in opinion
writing.
By writing a letter to the editor of Time
magazine to
protest a swipe that Time magazine took at
my favorite baseball
player in those days, the Minnesota Twins
talented utility player Cesar
Tovar, who once played all 9 positions
during a single game.
Time criticized the fact that Tovar got
one vote for
the American Leagues most valuable player
award in the 1967 season.
Triple Crown winner Carl Yastrzemski
resol, received all the other votes.
I rose to Tovar's defense as a worthy MVP
candidate with my outraged letter to the
editor of Time.
14 years old, at the time, I did not get
my
letter published, but I did get a letter
back from Time.
That I saved for many years.
It was on crisp white Time stationery,
addressed to Mr. Friedman.
And I was very impressed.
Somewhere there an opinion columnist was
being conceived.
My first exposure, though, to the
substance
of column writing, that is to politics
and business, came from being a caddy for
my father and some of his pals.
At the local golf club called Brookview.
There was a little bit of a Jewish Mafia
in Minneapolis back in the late 1940s and
50s.
And as a very young caddy, I remember
asking my father
about someone he knew who was convicted
and sentenced to jail time.
I asked what he had done, and my dad
gently explained to
me that he was, quote, shopping in a store
before it was open.
One of the great metaphors of all time and
maybe that is where my love of metaphors
came from.
I learned lots of worldly things as a
caddy
about whose business was doing well, who
was going bankrupt.
In fact.
First summer I learned what bankruptcy is
was on the,on the golf course.
I actually got my first sex education
course caddying also.
I caddied in 1970 U.S. Open for ChiChi
Rodriguez, a famous Puerto Rican golfer.
And one day ChiChi and I were standing on
the practice tee and ChiChi
was hitting shots with his hands while
providing a running commentary with his
mouth.
There was a small crowd watching from
behind.
You know, I used to be a teacher, Chi
Chi told the fans, as he walked [UNKNOWN]
the balls.
But I gave that up.
You know why?
I had this woman, she was a slicer.
I turned her into a hooker.
And after that, I gave up teaching.
I was 17 at the time.
I confess, I did not know what a hooker
was.
And all the adults around me were
laughing.
My father explained it to me.
My first sex education class.
But most of all what I took away from
Minnesota
in the fifties and sixties that has
influenced me my whole
life was a strong sense of belonging to a
community
and a certain optimism about how a
community can come together.
Through politics and philanthropy to make
people's lives better.
To put it simply, I learned from Minnesota
that politics can work.
Indeed in 1971, the year I graduated high
school, Time Magazine wrote a cover story
with our
governor Wendell Anderson on the cover
holding up
wall-eye, under the headline Minnesota,
the state that works.
When your senator's growing up are called
Eugene McCarthy, Walter Mondale, and
Hubert Humphry.
When the big companies around you are
called 3M, Dayton Hudson,
Target and UUU control data and they
believe it is their obligation
to build the symphony hall in the Tyrone
Guthrie theater, that corporate
social responsibility was something they
practiced
long before it was ever invented.
When your Congressmen in your
overwhelmingly Democratic district are two
liberal
Republicans and when your Congressman
today is the only African-American Muslim
in the US Congress, Keith Ellison, who is
from St. Louis
Park, you grow up believing that politics
can actually bring people together.
Bridge differences, and solve problems.
And that is the gift I took from my 18
years growing up in Minnesota.
The belief in the possibility.
Not the certainty, but the possibility,
that people will do the
right thing, and the outcome will be win
win for everyone.
So if there is a consistent theme to my
column, no matter
what the issue or problem, is to show
people the avenues and possibilities.
For compromise and win-win solutions.
I know that things can turn out well
because I saw it happen in my lifetime.
So that's why the title to, you know, this
chapter
and maybe to my whole career is always
looking for Minnesota.
Always looking for the middle ground.
Always hoping to find the better angels
from Beirut to Jerusalem to Washington,
DC.
But also not being surprised when I don't.
I know the world is not Minnesota.
You cannot live for a decade in Beirut and
Jerusalem and
cover wars and massacres and believe that
the world is Minnesota.
I recognize that pessimists are usually
right and I recognize
that even more so after twenty years of
writing a column.
But I also recognize that all the great
change in history was done by optimists.
Those who saw the possibility for building
win-win outcomes.
And so I make no apologies for trying to
buttress those people, and shine a light
on their efforts.
The world has enough pessimists.
I have the optimism corner, all to myself.
And growing up in Minnesota in the sixties
and seventies is where that came from.
My actual writing career started in two
stages.
The first was in high school, at Saint
Louis Park High in 1969.
When I took journalism as a sophomore from
our legendary high school journalism
teacher, Hattie Steinberg.
People often speak about the teacher who
changed their lives.
Hattie changed mine.
I took her Introduction to Journalism
course in tenth grade in 1967 in
room 313 and I have never needed or taken
another course in journalism since.
It was not that I was that good.
It was that she was that good.
Hattie was a woman who believed that the
secret
for success in life was getting the
fundamentals right.
And boy, she pounded the fundamentals of
journalism into her students.
Not simply how to write a lead or accurate
desc, transcribe a quote, but
more important how to comport yourself in
a professional way and always do quality
work.
To this day, when I forget to wear a
tie on assignment, I think of Hattie
scolding me.
I once interviewed an ad exec for a high
school paper who used a four letter word.
We debated whether to run it.
Had he ruled yes, that ad man almost lost
his job when it appeared.
She wanted to teach us about consequences.
Hatty was the toughest teacher I ever had.
After you took her journalism course in
tenth grade.
You tried out for the paper the echo which
he supervised.
Competition was fierce in 11th grade I
didn't quite come up to her writing
standards.
So she made me the business manager
selling pizza adds to local pizza parlors.
That year though she let me cover one
story, it was about an Israeli general
who'd been
a hero in the 6th day war who was
visiting, giving a lecture at the
University of Minnesota.
I covered his lecture and interviewed him
briefly afterwards, his name
was Ariel Sharon, it was the first story I
ever got published.
We would meet each other many times after
that.
Those of us on the paper in the
yearbook that she supervised, lived in
Hatty's classroom.
We hang out there before and after school,
now you
have to understand Hatty was a single
woman nearing 60
at the time, and she was the 19, and this
was the 1960s the was the polar opposite
of cool.
But we hung around her classroom like it
was the malt shop, and she was Wolfman
Jack.
None of us could articulated it then, but
it was because we
enjoyed being harangued by her,
disciplined by her, and taught by her.
She was a woman of clarity, in an age of
uncertainty.
We remained friends for 30 years, and she
followed
and bragged about and critiqued every
twist in my career.
After she died, her friend sent me a pile
of my stories that she had saved over the
years.
Indeed her students were her family, only
closer.
Judy Harrington, one of Hatty's former
student remarked, about
other friends who were on Hatty's
newspaper and yearbook.
We all graduated 41 years ago, yet nearly
each day in our lives,
something comes up, some mental image,
some
admonition that makes us think of Hatty.
Judy also told the story of one of Hatty's
last birthday parties when
a man said he had to leave early to take
his daughter somewhere.
Sit down, said Hatty, you're not leaving
yet.
She can just be a little late.
That was my teacher.
I sit up straight just thinking about her.
Basically, after high school I went to did
my undergraduate at Brandeis, but I.
Did semesters abroad at the Hebrew
University in
Jerusalem and the American university in
Cairo I
got a marshal scholarship to go to Oxford
to study Arabic an middle east history but
I
did my first year at the school in
Oriental and African studies in London
it's where I
met my wife who graduated from Stanford
and
was over at the llc and that's really
where.
My true journalism career began, began
totally accidentally.
At the time it was 1975.
Jimmy Carter was running against Gerald
Ford for president.
And the campaign was in its heated stage
back home.
And Ann and I were walking down the street
in London during the campaign.
And the Evening Standard, you're familiar
with the Evening Standard London after
newspaper.
They always have these blaring headlines
on the
newsstand to entice you to buy the paper.
You know, Brad to Jen 'We're finished.'
You know, something about, the Royals or
whatever.
Well, this day we're walking down the
street.
The newstand had this headline on it.
It said 'Carter to Jews' ; 'If elected I
promise to fire Doctor K.
Now what was that about?
I sort of stopped and looked at it.
Point it out to him.
I said isn't that interesting?
Jimmy Carter's running for president.
He's trying to bring Jewish votes, and
he's doing it
by promising to fire the first ever Jewish
Secretary of State.
Isn't that funny?
I've no idea what possessed me.
But I saw that headline, and I went back
to my
dorm room at London House and I wrote a
column about it.
What it meant.
And my then girlfriend, now wife, who is
from Des Moines, Iowa, took that column
home over
vacation, gave it to Gilbert Cranberg,
then the
legendary editorial page editor of the Des
Moines Register.
He liked it.
He printed it on a half page of the Des
Moines Register under an Alf cartoon, and
they paid me $50 and I thought that was
the coolest thing in the whole world.
I had been walking down a street.
I saw something.
I had an opinion about it.
I wrote it up and someone paid me $50.
And I was hooked ever after.
So my two years at Oxford, I wrote Op Ed
columns
for the Des Moines register in my own home
town, the
Minneapolis Star and Tribune all, some are
related to the middle
east, I got interested in the Middle East
also in high school.
And when i graduated from Oxford I applied
to jobs at AP and UPI.
The two wire services.
Competing wire services.
UPI doesn't exist anymore.
AP looked at my, my clips, it consisted of
a dozen columns for Mid-West
newspapers and said, very interesting kid,
but you've never covered a fire.
Let alone the city hall meeting.
Can't hire you.
But UPI being kind avis of wire service.
Had a great grizzled bureau chief back
then.
Leon Daniel.
And he said, if you can write a column we
could
probably taint, chea/p, treat, train you
to write a news story.
And since you have studied Arabic and the
Iranian revolution
happened and they seem to have the same
squiggly letters.
[SOUND] I think we'll hire you and give
you a chance.
So I actually started my career at UPI on
Fleet Street.
And to make a very long story short, I
worked
for them for two years covering the
Lebanese civil war.
Came home.
Was hired by the New York Times.
After a one hour emotional interview with
Abe Rosenthal where I explained why he
could actually send a Jewish report to
Beirut because I had already been there.
The New York Times hired me, sent me back
to Beirut in April 1982.
Israel invaded six weeks later.
It became the biggest story in the world.
I covered [UNKNOWN], the American embassy
bombing,
the marine bombing, all these amazing
stories.
My friend Phil Talbmann who's here came
out and actually joined me at one point.
I did that for, for two years, a little
more than two years.
I was sent to Jerusalem, I was the
Jerusalem Bureau chief until
1989, took a year off road from Beirut to
Jerusalem came back,
and then was the State Department
correspondent for the New York Times
beginning in 19 90 view with Jim Baker
thought it was a really.
Sorry, '89 with Jim Baker.
Thought it was a really boring job, and it
made
a terrible mistake until this wall in
Berlin suddenly came down.
And suddenly I found myself with a front
row seat to the end of the cold war.
Traveled 750 thousand miles with Baker as
the state department corresponded.
Then I covered the first year of Bill
Clinton's White House.
That was Mr. Toad's Wild Ride.
And, And then I did three years as the
chief economics correspondent.
And then, in January, 1995, they said,
you've done enough.
We think, now, you might have some
opinions.
And they made me the foreign affairs
columnist.
So, lets pick up the story there.
Because, as I say, everybody's writing
columns now, and I think
it's a wonderful thing.
But, the thing you need to understand
about
a column that's different from a news
story,.
Is that a column has to work.
No one would ever say about a news story
that works or doesn't work.
That's very interesting flyer that's very
interesting city hall meeting, very
interesting campaign.
News stories don't have to work, they
simply have to
tell you who, how, and where in a
compelling, interesting way.
But a column is different.
The column has to work.
What makes a column work?
What makes a column work is that it
produces a reaction.
News stories are meant to inform.
Columns are meant to produce a reaction.
So whether you're blogging or tweeting,
whether
you're doing a TED talk or YouTube-ing.
You gotta have in your back of the mind,
in
your mind, what is the reaction I'm
actually trying to produce?
And what I would argue is that there are
at least, I'm gonna give you nine.
Nine kinds of reactions, and if you
produce
any one of these nine, it's a column.
So the first reaction you wanna produce.
Possibly is that the reader reads your
column,
puts it down and says, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that.
It's good to break news in a column.
It's good to go places that others haven't
been.
Share an insight.
Inform people about something.
It should always be in the service of an
idea and an opinion.
But if someone reads your column.
I, I did a column about a Arab B&B
a couple months ago and someone emailed me
afterwards.
I really love this reaction.
He just said, who knew?
Who knew.
Who knew that 265 thousand people on New
Year's
eve rented out rooms in their house around
the
world to host someone on Arab B&B That
begin
the kick-off for writing about basically
the whole sharing economy.
But if you read a column where someone
puts it
down and says I didn't know that, that's a
good column.
Second, and this is a lot of what we do.
If someone reads your column and says, "I
never looked at it that
way, gosh thank you, you know I never ever
looked at it that way."
That's definitely a successful column.
I have an Indian friend who edits the
Indian Express and we
were talking a, a couple weeks ago and he
was telling me
that he did a column and I would use this
in my
book as an example of I'd never looked at
it that way.
You remember there was a huge controversy
about an Indian
diplomat who had underpaid her maid in New
York City.
And she was then, unceremoniously
arrested, and created a huge controversy.
And for weeks, it was all about the
diplomat,
and Indians rally to the diplomat, and
rally back.
And he did a column about the maid.
Because everybody forgot about the maid.
I thought that's a wonderful example of.
I never looked at it, that way.
You gave new way to look at it.
Your third kinda column, this is your
favorite, you'll live for this reaction.
Happens three or four times a year, if
you're lucky.
You said, exactly what I felt, but didn't
know how to say.
God, God bless you, God bless you, my son!
God Bless you.
Oh, when that happens that's just, that is
so satisfying, when
you can actually articulate what people
are feeling but haven't yet said.
Enormously satisfying.
Fourth reaction is very simple.
I want to kill you dead.
You annoy your offspring.
I want to waterboard you.
I want to beat you.
I want, I've canceled my subscription.
I absolutely hate you.
Okay.
Your column is defined as much by people
who are against it as who are for it.
And if you don't have anyone against you,
er,
chances are you don't have that many
people for you.
And every once in a while, you just have
to roar back.
And.
Act out.
Peel off somebody's skin or the skin of an
issue in a rip roaring way.
Wouldn't do it every day.
It can get a little old.
People can be exhausted by it, but every
once in awhile you need to do that.
It's very important though,I believe, I
practice.
Hunt big game.
Don't pick on little people and don't pick
on little ideas.
Hunt big game.
The fifth reaction and this one is really
hard.
Don't try this trick at home kids.
You made me laugh you made me cry.
That's a great if you can make people
really
laugh like my college Dale Collins if you
can
write about an emotional moment or that
drives an
opinion and make them cry that's a very
successful column.
When it's done well it's awesome.
When it's done badly it's cringe inducing
okay.
Being, try to be funny.
And not being funny.
Or trying to be sentimental, and not
actually touching people is awful.
Okay.
So, I don't do this very often, but every
once
in a while when you can do it, it really
worked.
Six reactions, you're calm - this is also
very important for people to remember.
Is when someone reads in your comments as
you said before,
as you said before, you have to repeat
yourself in this business.
Maybe you didn't read my Wednesday column
when I talked about this, maybe
you didn't see my Sunday column, maybe you
were out of town or traveling.
If you believe in an issue, you've gotta
drive it,.
And you've got to invent a language that
will stick in people's minds.
I often get criticized, I get criticized
for many things.
But one is, he's repeating himself again,
there he goes.
Oh, I do that deliberately.
Cause I, if you're gonna hate me, I really
want you to understand why.
Okay?
And I want you to never forget it, you
know.
I'm a big believer that to name something
is to own it.
If you can name an issue, you can own the
issue.
The world is flat.
Green is the new red, white, and blue.
So I spent a lot of time naming things.
I wanna stick in your head or in your
craw.
Either place is fine.
But I don't hesitate to repeat myself
because of that.
Obviously, in different ways.
Seven is.
This is really, really important reaction
to get from people.
You challenge me, you disappointed me.
Now what is this about?
I really believe it's important as a
columnist to challenge your base.
It's for liberal columnists to every once
in a while challenge liberals.
It's for conservatives to challenge
conservatives
never let anyone take you for granted.
Never let anyone feel they own you.
And when you do that when you anger and
rile your own base you will hear from
them.
But I think it's extremely important as a
columnist to check yourself.
By challenging your own base and a lot of
your own theories.
Eight, this is the one reaction you want
to avoid.
I knew what you were going to say by
reading your byline.
Oh that's death as a columnist.
That, that, that goes to the columnist who
never challenged their own base.
Where you become so predictable left,
right or centered that people
know what you're or think they know what
you're gonna say just by reading you bio.
That is definitely to be avoided.
And the last reaction,.
And, this happens rarely, but it's, I
think, a very important
one, is I bet that column didn't take very
long to write.
[LAUGH] Now, that's actually a compliment.
I'll tell you why.
The best columns, the very best columns I
feel I've written, came from some really
deep place.
And they came out so fast, and so quickly,
that it took me as
long as it took my fingers to hit the
keys, to write that column.
So when someone can feel almost that, that
column just
came straight out from some deep place,
that's a real compliment.
So those are, very quickly, the kind of
nine
reactions I'm looking for, as a columnist,
when I'm writing.
And if I produce any one of those nine, I
think I've got a column.
Now just quickly, before we go to
questions
in about 10, 15 minutes let me just
share with you some of the things I've
learned in the 20 years of doing this,
some of the lessons that I take away from
writing a column, and having been able to
travel around and see so many conflicts
and meet people and issues face to face.
I'd say the number one lesson that, that
I've learned is that,
and people who read me know that this
appears in my column
every so often, is that in the history of
the world, in
the history of all mankind, no one has
ever washed a rented car.
I'm a huge believer in that.
It's, it's one of my, just a guiding
principles in life, okay, that
in the history of the world, no one has
ever washed a rented car.
Someone always raises their hand and says,
I washed my rented car.
But, I think you know what I mean.
And first learned that from Larry Summers,
actually,
but I'm a big believer that ownership is
everything.
When people have a sense of ownership of
their company, when kids
have a sense of ownership over their
education, when teachers have sense of
ownership over their classroom, and most
importantly, when people have a sense
of ownership of their country and its
future, really good, good things happen.
And when people don't feel a sense of
ownership, bad things happen.
All these color revolutions we're seeing,
all these
Arab springs, are really about people who
have
been renting their countries from colonial
powers, kings
and dictators, their whole lives, and now
taking ownership.
And it's a beautiful thing to see.
But ownership is really the key to life,
because when people own
things, when, when people own their
companies, their future, their
classroom, they will always do so much
more then you can ever ask them to do.
And when they don't have the sense of
ownership, bad things really happen.
And that is a lesson I've seen, whether
I'm covering education or whether I'm
covering Tahrir Square.
Second thing I've really learned is that
there's two kind of editors.
There's editors who when you come to them
with a story
idea, they say, no that's, that, that,
that just doesn't work.
And there's editors who say, yes but.
Be a yes but person, because when someone
comes to you with a story idea
and you say, no that's never going to
work, they just go away depressed and
defeated.
When you say to them, yes, but that is
such a
great idea, but if you just make the third
graph the
lead, and you take the sixth graph and
move it up
the third, you give people a sense of
ownership over that story.
Man, they will take any piece of advice
from you, and they will run with that
story again, so much farther and faster
than anything you could demand of them.
Be a yes but teacher.
Be a yes but parent.
Be a yes but editor.
Third thing I learned is that the two most
important
words in foreign policy are self and
sustaining, self sustaining.
We are really good America, I've covered a
lot of this so
something I've learned the hard way, we
are really good at breaking things.
We are really good at breaking things.
There's no country we cannot break around
the world.
We've demonstrated that.
We are not good at building things.
We're like a football team with an offense
and no defense.
To put it another way
we, we can stop bad things from happening
in places, but we cannot make good things
happen.
That is the lesson I've taken away
from Bosnia, and Libya, and Iraq, and
Afghanistan.
To make a reality self sustaining is the
real challenge.
The real challenge is not what we do when
we are there, not what
surge we mount, but what we leave behind
and what is sustained after we go.
It doesn't matter if you're talking about
war,
doesn't matter if you're talking about
doing an
education project somewhere, doesn't
matter if you're talking
about trying to start or invest in a
company.
It's what is self sustaining is all that
really matters.
And it's unfortunately, I've seen too many
examples of
non self sustaining in the foreign policy
I've covered.
Another big lesson I've learned, and I
come across this all the time,
is that humiliation, in foreign policy, is
the single most powerful human emotion.
And, I've seen the impact of people
feeling humiliated and what they do.
You know, take away people's money,
they'll be angry, they'll be depressed.
Put them in jail, beat them, hurt them,
you'll get a backlash.
But humiliate someone, humiliate someone
and they'll wrap themselves
in dynamite, and blow you up or your twin
towers.
So much of what I cover in the world goes
back to humiliation.
Whether you're talking about Ukrainians
and Russians, Japanese and Chinese
or Arab Muslims in the Middle East and
America, I
feel I benefit most in covering foreign
policy from whatever
I've read about psychology, and whatever
I've read about humiliation.
It is the single most important emotion,
and it drives more foreign
policy issues than any other issue,
resources, money, nationalism.
Another big lesson I've learned.
I've alluded to the fact that I'm a caddy
and I'm a golfer,
and there are also just two kind of
golfers and two kind of countries.
So, Tom Watson had a famous caddy, Bruce
Edwards,
he tragically just died, died of Lou
Gehrig's disease.
But he caddied for Tom Watson his, most of
his
career except for three years, he caddied
for Greg Norman.
Then he went back to caddy for Tom Watson.
Afterwards, he did an interview and people
asked him
what was the difference between Greg
Norman and Tom Watson.
And he said, very simple, you caddy for
both these guys, and both
their balls they'd hit a perfect drive
down the middle of the fairway.
And each guy's ball would end in, end up
in a divot.
Greg Norman would say, my luck, I hit a
perfect drive.
If I didn't have bad luck, I'd have no
luck at all.
Look at this.
I'm in the, I hit this drive perfectly.
And Tom Watson would say, Bruce, watch
this.
There are really just two kind of golfers,
and
the truth is there just two kind of
countries.
There are those who say we're behind,
let's figure out what's
the best way to get ahead, the Meiji
restoration in Japan.
And there's those who say we're behind,
what did you do to me.
And there's a lot of countries and a lot
of people, who waste a lot of time
and energy complaining about being in the
divot, rather
than figuring out how to get out of it.
And I unfortunately have to spend a lot of
my time covering those countries.
Another big lesson I learned covering Jim
Baker, actually, Secretary of
State, is that success breeds authority,
and authority breeds more success.
And I learned this in a funny way.
I, I traveled with Baker on all 15 trips
he took
to the Middle East to put together the
Madrid peace process.
And on 14 of those trips, I came home and
wrote Secretary of State James A Baker,
III failed again to achieve his objective
of putting together a peace process.
And then trip 15, he succeeded.
He came back and stuck his finger in my
face
and said, Freedman, you're going to write
that I succeeded.
And he spiced that with a few other things
as well.
So we went off to Madrid and he,
he, convened the first, basically, region
wide peace conference.
It was a remarkable diplomatic achievement
and we actually flew
from Madrid, I never forgotten this, to
Nagorno, to, to, Azerbaijan.
And, he give a press conference in
Azerbaijan.
He'd just come from Madrid.
It was a world shaking story, covered all
over the world.
He stands up at the press conference in
Azerbaijan.
As every reporter stands up, first
question,
Mr. Baker, in light of what you've
achieved in Madrid, would you come here
and mediate now between our meninas and
azuries.
And I was a pool reporter.
Baker winked at me.
His eyes rolled.
The last thing he was going to do
was mediate between Armenia and Azerbaijan
over Nagorno-Karabakh.
But the lesson I took away from that, was
how quickly his success in
Madrid had translated into more authority,
and
more authority gave him leverage for more
success.
I think it's true whatever you do, small
victories, small victories can
add up to greater authority, and the
authority for really big victories.
Another really important lesson that I've
learned is that
there is a huge, huge difference between
skepticism and cynicism.
This is a really important issue for me
because unfortunately a lot of
people in my business have forgot where
the line is between skepticism and
cynicism.
Skepticism is about asking questions,
being
dubious, be wary, not being gullible.
Cynicism is about already having the
answers, or at least
thinking you already have them, about a
person or event.
The sceptics says, I don't think that's
true.
I'm going to check it out.
The cynic says I know that's not true.
It couldn't be.
He couldn't have done that for those
reasons.
I'm going to slam him or her.
The sceptic is in search of the truth.
The cynic is in search of snark.
There is such a thing, there is such a
thing as healthy scepticism.
There is no such thing as healthy
cynicism.
The cynic is always prejudging, and
prejudging is the
enemy of inquiry and learning, which
requires an open mind.
The truth is most of the journalists I've
ever known were not cynics.
Just the opposite, most of them are
rather idealistic, with a certain
underlying crusading spirit.
But cynic, cynicism is present enough in
our craft that it's worth constantly
guarding against.
If we want to be taken seriously, we have
to take our
subjects seriously, and that means doing
more than just sneering at them.
I learned this lesson early on in my
career in a odd series of events.
I was hired from UPI and joined the New
York Times business day staff.
That was where they, only job they had to
stash me in
at the paper when I came to New York, back
in 1981.
And on the staff, business day, was a
young editor named Nathaniel Nash.
And Nathaniel was a born again Christian.
He was deeply interested in the Holy Land.
Because I had covered the Middle East all
those years, we used to go out to lunch,
and he loved to hear about Israel and what
was going on in the Middle East.
So in May of 1982, sorry in April, when
the Times sent me off to,
to Beirut to be their correspondent, the
business
day staff had a goodbye party for me.
And Nathaniel pulled me aside at the end
of the
party and he said, I'm going to pray for
you.
I'm going to pray for your safety.
And I said Nathaniel, I so appreciate
that.
And I always considered it my lucky charm
when I was in Beirut.
And when I got out of Beirut, first day I
got out, I called Nathaniel and, and I
thanked him.
Now the book on Nathaniel, as a reporter,
was that he was too nice.
His colleagues always doubted that anyone
that nice could ever succeed in
journalism.
But somehow he triumphed over this
handicap.
And he went from one successful assignment
in business day, to Latin America, to
another.
And it was because Nathaniel intuitively
understood, I
always thought, the difference between
skepticism and cynicism.
I only wish I could have done for him what
he
did for me, because Nathaniel Nash, age
44, was the one
reporter on Commerce Secretary Ron Brown's
airplane, when it crashed into
a Croatian hillside on April 3, 1996,
killing everyone on board.
I was devastated.
With today's cacophony of magazine shows,
Oprah style interview sessions, and
talking heads, many people have lost sight
of what real journalists do.
Journalists do not appear on cable TV to
scream at each other.
Real journalists don't interview mothers
and daughters on daytime confession hours.
Real journalists don't have their own
shock jock radio shows.
Unfortunately, those are the people many
American see most in quasi-journalistic
roles, and these are people they think of
as journalists today.
Journalists are reporters like Nathaniel
Nash, who
go off to uncomfortable and often
dangerous
places, like Croatia, and get on a
military plane to chase after a visiting
dignitary, without giving it a second
thought, all to get a few fresh quotes,
maybe a scoop, or even just a paragraph of
color, that no one else has.
When I first heard the news about
Nathaniel, I whispered a prayer
for him, but I am sure that wasn't
necessary, for he was such
a good soul, who knew the difference
between skepticism and cynicism, that
I know he is sitting at God's elbow,
probably taking notes right now.
Another big lesson for me is most
people listen through their stomachs, not
their ears.
Really, most people do not listen through
They listen through their stomachs.
You connect with someone on a gut level,
as a reporter, as a columnist, or as a
leader, you don't have to bother them with
the
details at all, they know they've
connected with you.
You don't connect with someone on a gut
level, and you cannot show them enough
details.
Who remembers Anwar Sadat's speech, before
the
Knesset, after he flew from Cairo to
Jerusalem?
Nobody.
It was actually one of the harshest
speeches ever
given by an Arab leader about the
Palestinian cause.
No one in Israel remembers he even gave a
speech, because Sadat connected with
Israelis on a gut level.
And once he did, they did not care about
the details.
How do you connect with people on the gut
level?
I think it's by doing things that are
hard.
That are visibly hard and by taking a
risk.
[UNKNOWN] never connected with Israelis on
a gut
level, [UNKNOWN] has never connected with
Palestinians on
a gut level, and that's why each one
is always asking the other for one more
detail.
Cuz there is no gut connection.
gettin' here toward the end.
I just a few more.
I would say, one of the biggest things
I've learned
from covering the Arab Spring is really
how right Lennon was.
That if you don't have an organization
you've got nothing.
It's great to have a democracy movement
and talk really square or [UNKNOWN] and
[UNKNOWN].
But organization really is everything.
If you cannot translate your movement as
an organization
that can contest an election and deliver
your politics.
I cover a lot of people who haven't done
that, and that's
really been the theme of everything I've
been writing the last few years.
Professor at Columbia, Mark Mazower, wrote
this, I really like this.
He said that anger at corruption has
fueled number rallies all
over the past all over the world, over the
past few years.
Especially as austerity and high
unemployment have sharpened
the divides between haves and the have
nots.
Demonstrations however are an effective
means of ending corruption.
That takes institutional transformation.
A long slow slog.
Mostly invisible and untheatrical.
It's the opposite of street protest who's
power lies
in being as public, dramatic, and
instantaneous as possible.
What crowds in downtown [UNKNOWN] Kiev
have
in common was their extraordinary
diversity, but
this very quality also explains why they
have been incapable of sustaining a
political future.
The fundamental [UNKNOWN] insight still
holds,
nothing can be done without an
organization.
I've just been covering a lot of people
over the last three years in particular,.
We really need to learn that lesson.
Let me just close with, with a few more
personal ones.
One is about America and maybe a little
goes back to Minnesota, and that is that
pluralism, especially the pluralism we
have in this country, I see in this room,.
Pluralism is such an incredible thing.
And America is such a
freak.
We are freaks.
We have twice elected a black man who's
middle name
is Hussein who defeated a woman to run
against the Mormon.
Who does that?
Okay.
Nobody does that.
What we have in this country is so unique.
And
we treat it like it's a football.
We kick this country around like it's a
football.
It's
not a football.
It's a faberge egg.
We can drop it.
We can break it.
And in the interconnected, interdependent
world we live in.
To have mastered.
Pluralism?
Oh, and we're still a work in progress.
You need only look at the racism directed
at Obama to know that.
We are still a work in progress.
But to have gotten this far.
That,
I know you learned about comparative
advantage today.
That is the single most comparative
advantage.
We have as a country in the world.
And, we really need to take care of that
we need to appreciate it for what it is.
Big lesson that's really sustained me, I'm
a little Jewish guy
from Minnesota who spent the last 30 years
covering the Arab world.
And as anyone who read my copy knows, I
don't do it by going
around telling people how wonderful they
are.
How do you, how do you survive?
In that kind of environment?
As a journalist and then a columnist.
And tell the truth?
And to me it's one overriding thing I've
learned.
My survival mechanism being a good
listener.
Listening is the key to life.
Not only because of what you learn when
you listen but something more important.
When you actually listen to people don't
just wait for them to stop
talking, but actually listen to them, it's
amazing what they'll let you say back.
Because listening is a sign of respect.
And when you truly listen to people, it's
a
amazing what they will let you say,
because if people
think, you actually respect them, and that
you want a
good future for them, they will let you
say anything.
But if they smell you're not listening,.
That you really don't care what happens to
them.
You cannot tell them the sun is shining.
Something Dick Cheney and George Bush
never understood.
As much as they wanna liberate Iraq,
people there sensed, that they
really didn't respect them, and they
certainly weren't listening.
We're coming to the end here.
Couple
more.
Never drink the whole milkshake.
Especially never drink all of the other
guy's
milkshake.
One of my favorite pieces of movie dialog
from political science
is, you know the end of the film, There
Will be Blood,
the 2007 classic about, the ruthless
silver mining turned oilman, might have
turned oilman who could not stop at
anything to accumulate more wealth.
And you remember when Daniel Plainview,
the, the
oil driller basically takes Paul Dano, Eli
Sunday aside.
And Eli Sunday wants to sell him some more
land that he's
sure has oil and he says, drainage Eli,
drainage, Eli, you boy.
Drained it dry.
Sorry.
Here if you have a milkshake, and I have a
milkshake, and I have a straw.
There it is.
There's the straw.
You see.
You watching.
And my star reaches across the room and
starts to drink your milkshake, I drink
your milkshake.
Your whole milkshake.
I drink
it up.
Man, if there's one lesson I've learned
from covering the Arab Spring.
It's do not try to drink the other guys
whole milkshake.
This is about no victor, no vanquished.
If you don't leave space for the other
people, whether
it's Ukrainians leaving space for the
Russian speakers among them.
Whether it's Sunnis leaving space for
Shiites or Shiites leaving space for
Sunnis.
If you want it all and try to get it all,
you will end up with nothing.
The Arab spring that has been done the
best so far.
Interesting the one we have had the least
to do with,Tunisia.
Why?
Because they've operated there on the
principal, no vanquished,
no victor, you get your milkshake I get
mine.
Big lesson I got early in my career in
journalism,
never ask the competition to hold the
phone for you.
This is the first lesson I ever learned as
a journalist.
When I was a cub reporter just starting
out in London, the first real news story
that
my editors at UPI sent me to was in
the Iran, covered the Iranian embassy
takeover in London.
It involved pro-Khomeini Iranian students.
Somehow I managed to talk my way into
the building, interviewed some of the
student rebels.
I don't remember what they said but I was
so excited by whatever
it was that I ran right to the phone booth
next to the embassy.
Big red old British style phone booth.
No cell phones back then.
It was one of these classics.
There was a long line.
I got in line.
All these other grizzled Fleet Street
reporters who wanted to file their
stories.
I patiently waited to my turn at the
phone.
When I got inside the booth, I excitedly
called my editors at UPI.
I, telling them everything I had seen and
heard from inside the embassy.
Reading from pages in my notebook.
At one point though, one of the editors
said to me, taking down my dictation.
Can you check this detail in the Embassy?
I said, wait a minute, I'll check.
I opened the door of that little red phone
booth, and said to the
fleet step reporter standing in line
behind me, do me a favor, hold the phone.
Then, I dashed out of the phone booth.
Before I had taken two steps, the guy in
line behind me slipped into the booth,
slammed down
the receiver, started dialing his own
newspaper, and turned
to me to say two words, I will never
forget.
Sorry mate.
Never ask the competition to hold the
phone for you.
Now I will conclude on a very personal
note for all you business students,
always be a big tipper, always be nice to
the help, and always call your mother.
Okay, always be a big tipper.
I learned this from my friend the film
maker George Stevens.
You know if you are a big tipper it may
actually add up to $5,000.
Yeah, up to $5,000.
If your a big tipper every day every meal
your whole life.
But you'll make a difference in someone
else's life.
You'll actually be giving them a sign of
respect.
Always be a big tipper.
Always, always be nice to the help.
It's not only the right thing to do but I
can tell
you as a reporter, the secretaries who
have been putting me through
to their boss, the policeman who have let
me through a barricade
because I was nice to them when it didn't
count really came back.
To serve me later.
Always be nice to the help, and lastly
this is advice I always give at every
graduation.
Always call your mother.
Where's my daughter?
Whenever I've had the honor of giving a
college graduation speech, I always end
it with this story about the legendary
University of Alabama football coach Bear
Bryant.
Late in his career after his mother had
died, South Central
Bell Telephone Company asked Bear Bryant
to do a TV commercial.
As best as I can piece together, the
commercial was supposed to be very simple.
Just a little music.
And Coach Bear Bryant saying in his tough
gravely voice, have you called your mama
today?
On the day of the filming though, he
decided to ad lib something.
He reportedly looked into the camera and
said, have you called your mama today?
I sure wish I could call mine.
His
mother had just died, and that was how the
commercial ran.
And it got a huge response from audiences.
So if you take anything away from this
lecture, please take this.
Call your mother always, and your father.
I wish I could call mine.
So I'm fresh out of ammo here folks.
Let me just conclude by saying this.
That's why I want to write this book on a
column, right?
This is where my opinions come from.
And that's what constitutes a real column.
And these are some of the things that I've
learned writing one for 20 years twice a
week.
It's still the best job in the world.
I have to tell you.
I've got the best job in the world.
And somebody has to have it.
I've got it and you don't.
Okay?
I get to be a tourist with an attitude, go
where
ever I want, write whatever I want, about
whatever I want.
Some 45 years after taking journalism in
that room at 313
room 313 at Sandal's Park High school, I
can honestly tell you
that I'm as excited about writing my next
column as I
was my first and I am also Les still
looking for Minnesota.
That's why I'm gonna end where I begin,
with the Jersey Boys.
Because the closing lines of that musical
play
resonate with me just like the opening
ones.
This time it's Frankie Valli talking,
looking back on his
remarkable career as the lead singer of
the Four Seasons.
They ask, he says, What was the highpoint?
The Hall of Fame?
Selling all those records?
Pulling Sheri out of the hat.
It was all great.
But the first time the four of us made
that sound, our sound, when
everything dropped away and all there was
was the music, that was the best.
That's why I'm still out there singing
like that bunny on TV with the battery.
I just keep going and going and going.
Chasing the music...
Trying
to get home.
Thank you very much.
[SOUND]